in this video we'll talk about the
process of receptor mediated endocytosis
but before that let's learn what is
endocytosis endocytosis is a cellular
process in which substances are brought
into the cell
and
there are three categories of
endocytosis
named as receptor-mediated endocytosis
phagocytosis and pinocytosis this
particular video will focus on the
mechanism of receptor-mediated
endocytosis
receptor-mediated endocytosis begins at
the surface of the cell
and it involves receptor ligand
interaction so here are a lot of
receptors which are displayed on the
surface which can pos possibly bind with
these ligands
after ligand binding there would be
recruitment of adapter proteins
in the cytosolic half of this receptor
these adapter proteins are really
crucial in this process of
receptor mediated endocytosis
there are additional proteins known as
bar family proteins which leads to
membrane curvature
not shown in this animation
but the membrane would
be
curved and they would it would
invaginate towards the cytoplasmic side
there would be recruitment of molecules
known as clattering this clathrin
organize themselves with the help of
these adapter proteins and forms a
clathrin coat and this is known as a
clathrin coated vesicle
after a while these clathrin coated
vesicles would hang from the membrane
and the protein known as dynamine would
actually pinch off this vesicle
from the membrane and the vesicle is now
internalized
once internalized this vesicle can fuse
with the endosome
and inside the endosome the ph is low
that is why there would be dissociation
of the ligands from the receptor
now the question is what would happen to
this receptor and the ligand
there could many possibilities that can
that can be
understood
so first
there is a possibility where receptor is
recycled back and the ligand is degraded
there is also another possibility where
the receptor is recycled and the ligand
is also recycled
there is also another possibility where
the receptor is degraded and also the
ligand is degraded and let me give you
an example
so
in case of ldl endocytosis
the
ldl particle is actually processed
digested inside the endosome but the ldl
receptor is displayed back on the
surface
in case of iron transport with the help
of
iron carrier transferrin and
transferring receptor both transferring
receptor and transferrin is displayed
back on the surface so that means
receptor and ligand are both recycled on
the surface
in case of let's say epidermal growth
factor receptor both receptor and ligand
is degraded and this is one of the
mechanism by which the signaling
via egfr
is uh regulated so now we understand how
receptor-mediated endocytosis works and
also the nitty-gritty details in this
particular video all the notes
associated with this video is found in
my
facebook page the link is provided in
the description don't forget to check
out and like that page
anyway if you like my video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can support my
channel in patreon if you're an indian
viewer viewer you can support my channel
via beam upi app
my courses are present in academy which
is india's biggest large uh biggest
online learning platform using our code
ap 10 you can get a 10 discount on the
subscription i'm also presenting all the
social media the links are provided in
the description so feel free to connect
with me
see you in the next video
[Music]